then you can do what you want well that
may not be the plan anymore a source
tells ET that olivia jade has no plans
to return to USC nearly four months
after news of the College Admission
scandal broke we're here today to
announce charges in the largest college
admissions scam ever prosecuted by the
Department of Justice quote she never
wanted to attend USC to begin with and
now she is sure that USC isn't the place
for her right now her goal is to rebuild
her brand and her business today I get
to review and I know my highlight
palette with Sephora collection the
source adds that the YouTube star has
been turning to her dad fashion mogul
Massimo for business advice quote he has
been encouraging Olivia to create a new
brand either makeup or beauty related
Lori Lachlan and her husband are accused
of paying $500,000 in bribes to get
Olivia and Bella admitted to USC as
recruits for the crew team even though
neither of them participated in the
sport they have pleaded not guilty on
all charges
but the source explains that the girls
are definitely scared for their mother
and father quote until the court date
has passed they are just trying to get
through the summer we're just a nice
normal family you know like we don't we
don't have anything outrageous really
happening back in May a source told et
Olivia is having a very hard time
dealing with this and for the most part
she's cut herself off from her mother
and is going out and partying a lot but
just last month another source told ET
that Olivia's relationship with her mom
has improved last week both Olivia and
Bella returned to social media to wish
their mom a happy birthday I saw it on
the Instagram page and we were freaking
out now ET source says that therapy has
been the key to bringing the family back
together Lori has apologized many times
to her girls and has told them that she
only wants the best for them Olivia has
forgiven her but she still carries some
resentment
because she realizes that this scandal
has marked her and will never entirely
go away
[Applause]
[Music]